hi guys it's over at again and today I'm
I will be doing a tutorial on planning
and I know that in the past I have to a
certain extent always said that I never
planned my roller coasters and yeah like
I said this is true to a certain extent
of course because there's always some
planning you can't just do whatever
whenever because you cook so it's going
to look like a total mess if you don't
plan anything there's always some kind
of plan in your head and there's always
some major guidelines of what you want
to do now the trick is to get these
things right because they're actually
very important to getting your coaster
right in the later stage it's actually
not as important that you get the small
details and small scenery things down
but the entire picture is actually very
important thing as well now the way I
usually go around this is for paths I
just take my ground and just scatter
some sand wherever I want to add paths
later on and terraforming is easy
because you're just going to do some
random terraforming here and there and
one thing that's actually the color
scheme now this actually gets easier the
more coast as you build because you just
got used to the color schemes there are
I mean every color scheme has been tried
at some point in time you can you can
well you can be fairly sure of that of
course there can't be any ridiculous
color schemes like this one for example
just some random colors nobody's ever
done this before but then again it
doesn't really look too great you can
you can be sure that all the
good-looking color schemes are already
used of course you can come up with some
color schemes that are somewhat gimmicky
but still look good but one thing is
that a color scheme has to fit with the
theme of a coaster now one thing I
usually do to test the color scheme is I
just built a few custom supports just
some test supports to see what the color
what the color combinations look like
that I want to test so right here I'm
just going to drop some random sports
now this actually looks really good I
might actually stick with this color
combination I actually really like it I
think it's like Kumar in real life but
that doesn't really matter like a
certain many color schemes have already
been used
but for example if you want to have an
African coaster or is something jungle
ish a green track is very common the
color orange is pretty common but if you
want to have a class that is themed with
the see something like Manta SeaWorld
you're going to have to want to use some
blue colors like a light blue color for
the track and dark blue colorful sports
that always works out and I have to say
that blue and purple always look very
nice as well they really complement each
other say goes for green and you still
get that sea feeling right tear that sea
theme not as soon as I start making them
red again you get a contrast in the
colors because right and blue of course
a complete opposites and you get
somewhat more generic color scheme right
here and yeah that's basically how it
goes so most tropical coasters call us
like that pretty dark generic is usually
very light alien is always black purple
dark blue maybe this dark red color
although this is also kind of horror if
you can if you don't need to use it
avoid the blue or red track with white
support but because that's been overdone
to oblivion it's ridiculous I'm talking
about this called a scheme right here
you see it a lot and it gets boring
after a while so if you want to create a
unique coaster don't do this if you want
to recreate something or make it just
make a generic oh so you can do this but
this is a very overused thing but I feel
like doing that color scheme which I
just accidentally stumbled upon on the
first try which is to start blue with
rats so I'm settled I'm settled with
that and also compliment I don't know
why but it looks great with this light
brownish I used for their walls right
there and right then the next thing to
do is some planning of the terraforming
some very light planning just planning
up some terraforming next to the coaster
now I feel like like this is just a
little trick but I I sometimes get
comments on my videos of why is there
always a lake in your video now of
course I I yeah lost that habit which is
a good thing because you should always
have a lake
but a lake is always a nice thing I mean
not even necessarily for a splashdown
it's just just some scenery interaction
just a change of scenery
it's also a tip I would like to give you
again just a small tip while playing
this never have the same kind of scenery
all over the place even if your ghost is
on a mountain or something or with no
scenery other than the foliage never
have the same foliage and the same
things all over the place if you want to
have a coaster just emitting the nature
without any buildings or other scenery
then fine but be sure to use different
kinds of trees and add some Lakes here
and there just to just for some
variation and of course isn't natural
but remember that everything along a
coaster is going to be planned these
things cost millions of dollars and yeah
engineers even plan the the foliage
around the coast is usually so always be
sure to plan this as well just because
it makes it turn it's a realistic aspect
of it
I mean real-life coasters are planned
and if you plan your coasters sure
they're going to get that planned
look but that's actually what you want
to go for because the coast is not
something that nature drops in there
it's not like they manifest by some
weird God never mind I'm drifting almost
terribly well anyway I'm just rambling
and building some random things I just
want to have some different plateaus for
my paths to be on so that's what I'm
building right now just some simple
planning stuff I think I'm just going to
yeah I don't really know what this is
but I might add some buildings to this
or something like that I'm going to
extend it a little make it come closer
to the coaster and then hmm you know
what I might actually make this a little
river kind of thing
just to make it a bit bigger otherwise
it's just going to be that small pond
that's not doing anything there except
for being there that's also a bit boring
right so now we've actually got a body
of water at least we don't we don't
really have water in it yet but it's
going to be a body of water and it's
going to be next to drop and this is
actually something that I almost always
use I
use the [ __ ] out of this I'm sorry for
that but I often use this just because I
gives you some nice camera placement
that's it if you have a lake right here
there's no reason to know anything so
you have a perfect overview of the
coaster right here and same goes for
here and it's just nice you can take
nice shots using water that's actually
about the only reason why I do this plus
real-life coasters often have bodies of
water next to it as well though right so
that's about it for the planning to be
honest it's not really that much more to
plan right here right I need to lower
this a bit though you know what no I
need to make this bit higher and I'm not
sure how much I'm going to extend this
but I might I can always do that in the
later stage remember you don't really
have to do everything yet it's just some
planning ahead just for yourself and I
know I always used to think that I
didn't need any planning but if you plan
ahead really your coasters are going to
look better because you can come up in
your head with some ideas and you can
save them so to speak on your map and
just next time you're on it you're like
hmm oh yeah that's why I wanted to do so
you can still work in that same kind of
workflow that you were in before you
left again right so that's about that
I'm going to just adds a little plateau
right here so I can have some stairs I
want this to be just normal sea level
whatever level the usual ground is
though and I'm going to add some stairs
in here so I'm already going to smooth
that out a bit so I can actually plan
the paths right so I know that I want to
have some paths in here because I just
built all that stuff right there so and
then it'll go along this curve and have
a thing on this I don't know I'm not
sure what yet I'm not sure what I'm
going to add here yet but I'm probably
going to make it a wall made out of
stone or something and have
it have an overview of the coaster and
little lake right here just some some
experimental thing that never be afraid
to experiment never be afraid to do some
new things because otherwise you're not
going to discover new things some
sometimes I'm just doing random stuff
and then I look at it and I'm like hey
that actually looks pretty cool and
that's actually the best way to find
some new stuff right so I think I'm
going to adjust the curve of this and
it's all because on the station cue is
going to need some room right so now I'm
going to add the cue right there so this
is also station area I'm going to need
this area for the cue and if I want to I
can always bring the path around that
area and add some stuff in here as well
right but that's all just um some vague
plans that I'm not really too short not
to certain of yet I mean I'm probably
not going to add anything there though
it would be really nice I have to admit
that it always looks nice when you've
got a little pathway around here with a
little wall just just a walkway than
some water and a coaster on the other
side doing its dropping inversions and
stuff but then again it's going to take
me a lot of work so I might not do that
well I'll see I might remove that
eventually right so now I do want to
finish the little water thingy but then
I'm finished for today though so that's
about it for the planning you can
already see wherever where everything's
going to be just going to be some
buildings in here probably stations
going to be over here the exit path is
probably going to lead over here I
suppose though it could also go here I'm
not too sorry
sure of that the queue is going to be
here and come out here there and this
will be a lake which I want to finish
today so I'm going to do that real quick
all right if you're smoothing out it's
always handy to put this thing on line
because otherwise it's going to take a
lot of time because the smoothing tool
is a bit slow
right now this doesn't look too smooth
yet so I'm going to smooth especially
the borders of this now whatever is
underwater is not too important but I
would still recommend you to make it as
least look pretty nice because if you
like me and you've got the the good
graphics on this game you can look
through the water so if there's some
ugly looking stuff on in there it's not
really nice to look at but just some
sand will do but just be sure that you
smooth it out enough right
so what I usually do for this because um
as you can see these hills on the sides
aren't steep enough to add some water to
it is make a small gap and then try to
add water but apparently that's not
working out because it's a located a
little bit too high rights so need to
find someplace else now this should work
out but it's still not working and
that's a bit weird I'm going to test it
somewhere else then because it should be
working right it works never mind
and I can see the problem already it's a
little bit too let a little bit too high
I mean um think oh well that's not
really good oh well maybe if I smooth it
out it's not going to remove oh no it
won't okay perfect right now though no
that's not perfect no no no no big fat
nope nope it's not it's not really yeah
it's way too shallow never mind that
I always yeah I really thought that was
something fishy going on my almost
forgot that I wanted to have water over
there as well right now this should be
good I don't want to make it more deep
than it already is
because it's just a hassle with supports
and all that your your rivers and lakes
honestly they don't have to be that deep
though if you're making a big one of
course that has to be deep and then your
plot then you're probably not going to
build anything over it so
really matter anyway right so I usually
use this tool and lower it a little and
this is perfect and then smooth it out
again right so that's it for today and
you can see all the playing already and
in the next episode I'm going to start
working the station so till that